Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile before my hands start shaking.
You posted a question.
I'm a cybernetic organism.
This episode is brought to you by wordpress.com I love wordpress.
I have used it for so many years.
It's my goto platform for blogging and creating websites.
I use wordpress.com for everything every day.
My site,
tim.blog is built on it.
The websites for my books,
including tools of titans,
tribe of mentors.
It's all in wordpress.com and the founder Matt Mullenweg.
One of my close friends has appeared on this show many times.
Just search Matt Mullenweg,
Tequila Ferris for quite an exciting time.
Whether you're looking to create a personal blog,
a business site,
or both,
you can make a really big impact right out of the box when you build on
wordpress.com and you'll be in good company.
It's used by the New Yorker,
Jay Z,
Beyonce,
five 38 tech crunch,
Ted,
CNN,
and time just to name a handful,
and one of my friends@googlewhoshallremainnamelesshastoldmethatwordpress.com
offers the best out of the box SEO imaginable end quote,
and it's one of the many reasons that nearly 30% of the Internet is run on
wordpress.
You do not need experience or to hire someone that's perhaps the best part.
wordpress.com guide you through the entire experience.
They have hundreds of designs and templates that you can use and it's easy to
get started.
There's no need to worry about security upgrades,
hosting any of that.
They have for 24 seven support and they're very,
very responsive.
If you have questions,
they get right back to you.
And this allows you to create the highest quality with the least amount of
headache and friction.
So if you're building a website,
period,
when my friends come to me and ask what I use,
what I recommend they use,
the answer is wordpress.com so check it out.
If you want to get started today,
learn more with a 15% discount off any new plan.
Go to wordpress.com forward slash Tim to create your website and find the plan
that's right for you.
So learn more.
Take a look,
wordpress.com forward slash Tim for 15% off a brand new website.
Check it out.
This episode is brought to you by four sigmatic.
You might remember four sigmatic for their mushroom coffee,
which was created by those clever finished founders.
And when I first mentioned that coffee on this podcast,
the product sold out in less than a week.
It lights you up like a Christmas tree,
which can be really useful.
However,
recently I've been testing the opposite side of the spectrum of new product and
that is their Reishi mushroom elixir to help me end my day to get to sleep.
As you guys may know,
longtime listeners,
at least I struggled with insomnia for decades.
I've a largely fixed that but still shutting off my monkey brain has never been
easy,
still isn't easy very often and I found Reishi,
which I've been fascinated by for a few years now,
has been very,
very effective and calming their old formula,
however,
four Sigmadek old formula included Stevia and I like to avoid sweeteners,
all sweeteners for a host of reasons and I then just ping them and asked,
hey guys,
I would love to experiment with this and maybe actually suggested,
but I'd like a version without sweeteners if he'd be open to it.
If too much of a headache,
don't worry.
And they are always game for experimentation.
So they created a special custom version without the Stevia,
without sweeteners.
Now it is part of my nightly routine.
Their ratio looks or comes in single serving packets which are perfect for
travel and in fact I'm about to leave the country right now and I have a packet
in front of me that's just going to sit in the end of my carry on bag.
You only need hot water and it mixes very,
very easily.
Here's some recommended copy that they put in the read.
So I'm going to read it and then I'll give you my take quote,
a warning for those in the experimental mindset,
Reishi is strong and bitter in parentheses,
like any great medicine.
So if the bitterness is too much,
I recommend trying it with honey end or nut milk such as almond milk and quote.
So I'm going to say no,
you should suck it up and you should drink the tea because it's not that bitter.
And maybe you should take the advice of all Chinese people when they're
criticizing younguns.
When they say [inaudible] should a cool,
which means you're not able to eat bitterness.
Bitter is in many cases,
an indication of things that help liver detoxification and so on.
Not saying that's the case here,
but I've tested this ratio lecture on family members,
on friends.
Everybody has liked it.
It's a little bit earthy.
It's not that hard.
So I would just say suck it up and no,
don't put in honey or nut milk or any of that shit.
Just drink the goddamn tea.
It's delicious,
I think,
right?
If you like poo air,
that kind of stuff,
that type of tea,
you're going to dig it.
So just try it.
Okay.
Back to then my read.
If you'd like to naturally improve your sleep,
both onset and quality,
I think naturally you might just enjoy this ratio elixir without any sweeteners.
It has organic,
Reishi extract,
organic fuel to mint extract,
organic rose hips extract,
organic Tulsi extract.
And that's it.
No fancy stuff,
no artificial watching McCall at anything.
So check it out.
Go to foursigmatic.com forward slash and Ferris and get 20% off this special
batch.
I don't know if they're gonna be making much more of this,
uh,
since it was made specifically for you guys to do me a favor and try it out so
that they continue to be open to experimenting with me to create products for
you guys.
Specifically.
Check it out.
Four sigmatic,
that's [inaudible] dot com forward slash Ferris,
F,
e R,
I s,
s and get 20% off the special batch.
And you must use the code of Ferris to receive your discount.
So again,
go to foursigmatic.com forward slash Ferris and then use code Ferris for 20% off
of this rare exclusive,
limited run of Reishi mushroom elixir for nighttime routines with out any
sweeteners.
Enjoy.
Yeah.
Hello boys and girls.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another episode of the Tim Ferriss Show where
it is my job each and every episode to deconstruct world class performers,
experts from various disciplines across all industries.
And today we have Brandon Stanton who is the creator of the Number One New York
Times bestselling books,
humans in New York,
humans of New York stories as well as the children's book,
little humans of New York.
In 2013 he was named one of the 30 under 30 people changing the world by Time
magazine.
Brennan has told stories from around the world in collaboration with the United
Nations and it was invited to photograph President Obama in the Oval Office.
His photography and storytelling blog,
humans of New York is followed by more than 25 million people plus me on several
social media platforms.
He's a graduate of the University of Georgia and lives in New York City.
You can find his work on Instagram at humans of and why is in New York on
Facebook,
humans of New York,
humans of New york.com and a video series based on the blog recently became one
of the first pieces of original content acquired by Facebook.
So you can find that as well.
Humans of New York,
the series.
Okay.
Brandon,
welcome to the show.
Thanks Tim.
I really appreciate you making the time and I've been following your work for
quite a few years now and uh,
I'm excited to have a chance to,
to pick it some of the earlier days and explore questions that had been on my
mind for a few years now.
So the,
uh,
the,
the first question I wanted to take a stab at is actually one I'm borrowing from
another Jorgen.
Uh,
and that is a joke Gibeah the cofounder of Airbnb.
Who likes to ask this question?
Do you remember the first time you got in trouble or one of the first times you
got in trouble?
No.
God
had the first time I got in trouble
or a notable time that you got in trouble when you were young?
A notable time.
I remember,
um,
I was sitting in,
my mom used to take us to the grocery store a lot of times after school and do
you know,
she was just going to run in for a few minutes and grab something and so we just
supposed to sit in the car.
Um,
and I think I was like,
you know,
nine or 10,
um,
and I wasn't supposed to touch anything but there were all these like buttons on
the dashboard and things like that.
And um,
I remember she came
back out and I think,
you know,
the alarms going off and then the,
the keys,
the steering wheel's locked and you can't move the car.
And I remember that one very vaguely because I wasn't allowed to go to the fall
festival at the school that year.
Um,
which was a,
um,
my favorite thing to do cause they had like carnival games and things like that.
Um,
so going back in my mind about the,
you know,
a painful early time of getting in trouble,
that comes into mind
as I was doing homework for this conversation,
I was reading up on some of the earlier days and the particular sense that I
wanted to explore.
Uh,
I was in a previous interview of yours and it covers quite a bit of it,
but it said after having flunked out of college in later going back and
graduating as a history major with straight A's and then it goes on to say a
number of other things.
Right.
But did you get into a lot of trouble as a kid or what,
what led to the flunking out of college?
Right.
Well,
I mean,
I always say that,
you know,
a lot of my early trouble,
uh,
was coming from this thought that I had to do something really big in the world.
And,
you know,
I'm sitting in class all day and I'm learning these kind of,
very minute details about things like the magna Carta and,
you know,
the compromise of 18 whatever.
Uh,
and none of this really seemed important at all because,
you know,
I felt that I felt that I was,
my purpose had to be much greater than this and then how am I going to use any
of this in life.
Um,
and so like,
you know,
I spent all of my time,
back then I was smoking a lot of weed.
Um,
and just like trying to think about what my big idea and what my contribution to
the world was going to be and instead of going to class,
I was doing that,
you know,
instead of really kind of working to improve myself,
I was doing that just,
you know,
pontificating and then just like thinking all the time about,
what my contribution to the world is going to be a,
and that was the time that I flunked out.
And you know,
things really started moving forward for me was when I threw in the towel,
you know,
I waved the white flag.
I said,
you know,
I'm going to stop trying to figure out,
what the big thing I'm supposed to accomplish is,
and I'm just going to start doing what I was supposed to do.
And you know,
I started riding the bus and started going to community college,
Georgia Perimeter College.
I got my grades back up.
I went back to the University of Georgia where I flunked out of.
And you know,
I focused on becoming a disciplined person and you know,
having a routine in my wife of working out every day and playing piano every
single day,
doing my homework.
And you know,
funny because when I stopped trying to think about this big thing that I was
going to accomplish in life and started just focusing on putting one foot in
front of the other every single day,
it began to propel me on the journey that ultimately led to humans of New York,
which was something bigger than I could've ever imagined when I was hitting the
bong and the Creswell dorm.
That's the University of Georgia
now.
This preoccupation that you had with your big contribution to the world.
I don't know how common that is.
I didn't have that preoccupation.
Did Dee,
did that come from parents?
Did that come from a book you read or where did that come from?
Psychedelic mushrooms might've had a little something to do with it.
I can see that.
It's just like,
I spent so much time,
you know,
I had a very intelligent group of friends and you know,
so much of my 16,
was just,
uh,
I guess partaking in these recreational activities,
trying to figure out what is truth,
you know,
like what is,
what is the meaning of all of this?
And like all of these kind of big questions,
uh,
compared to which,
you know,
these intricacies of things like calculus and Algebra and,
verb conjugations and French and,
you know,
all of these subjects I was being forced to do in schools seem so minor and not
useful to what I really wanted to understand.
And you know,
alongside these kind of like big questions about,
you know,
why are we here and,
and what is this all about Cain,
this kind of feeling.
And you know,
I think some sort of kind of vague,
like spirituality was wrapped up in it as well,
that,
you know,
this is this,
this world is so amazing and the fact that we're here is so amazing and doing
anything less than something amazing is kind of squandering,
you know,
this,
this whole reason that you're here.
Um,
and I think that's,
that was the kind of thinking,
you know,
that brought me down this path that I was,
my time was too good and,
and my thoughts like,
you know,
the,
the space in my brain was too precious to,
you know,
fill it up with all these,
little this homework and this and this stuff that seemed so unimportant.
Uh,
and so instead,
I just,
you know,
spent all my time just kind of grappling with these,
with these bigger things.
What was it like growing up in Marietta,
Georgia and my right.
And were you born in Georgia also?
Yeah.
I was born in Georgia.
I mean I am somebody who has liked everywhere I've ever been.
I liked my school.
I liked my college,
I liked the community college I went to after I flunked out of my college.
I liked Atlanta.
Uh,
I liked Chicago.
I love New York.
You know,
I'm generally somebody who appreciates the,
the place that I'm in a,
I tend to find that people complaining about where they live.
Not always.
I mean it's,
it's not.
You can,
there's always someplace that you can be,
that might be better for you,
but if you hate the place that you live,
if you,
if you kind of just despise it.
Um,
I find that a lot of times a new environment is not the key to your happiness.
Uh,
cause I find it a lot of times the people that are complaining about one place
when they moved to another place,
then you know,
if it's,
if they live in Atlanta and the answers New York,
then when they get to New York,
you know what New York's dead.
The answer is La,
when they get to La,
oh,
the American values suck.
Need to get to Paris,
you know,
when they get,
when they get to Paris,
Oh,
you know,
the West is so,
it's so materialistic.
I need to go to India.
You know what I mean?
And so I find a lot of times to place it kind of the people who kind of
externalize their environment as being the reason for their dissatisfaction tend
to be unsatisfied everywhere.
Uh,
I kind of the opposite.
You know,
I've loved every place that I've lived.
I've loved the people.
Um,
you know that I've met in every place I lived.
Marietta was Starbucks and Barnes and noble,
but I had a great,
great group of friends and you know,
I enjoyed growing up there.
This,
I'm just piecing the connective tissue together as I go because I'm really
interested,
I don't know why this is the case,
but it,
particularly in the last six months,
I've been more and more fascinated by the earlier stages with almost everyone.
I've been chatting with the history major,
you graduate with straight A's and then you end up,
and I know you've,
you've,
you've spoken quite a bit about this,
we won't Belabor the point,
but you get a job as a bond trader in Chicago is my understanding and it that
right?
The first time that you weren't embarrassed in front of family and friends about
where your life was going,
you get this,
this prestigious job.
How did,
how did you go about choosing that job or finding that job?
Or how did they find you from history?
Right,
right.
So,
I mean,
the whole reason I became,
I mean to give you,
to catch you up a little bit,
um,
you know,
when I first went to the University of Georgia,
I was majoring in business.
That's when I wasn't going to class.
Uh,
I flunked out.
and then when I decided to go back to college,
you know,
I thought to myself,
well,
I'm just going to
study something that I enjoy anyway,
so it's not this kind of,
you know,
major force of effort to go to class and to do my work.
Um,
at that time I had developed a reading habit that was really when my life kind
of turned around.
Cause remember,
you know,
I,
I stopped thinking about these kinds of big problems I wanted to solve and you
know,
I started focusing on,
you know,
establishing a routine,
some discipline in my life.
And one of the first big ones and still,
probably the most monumental routine that I ever established and decision I ever
made was that I was going to read 100 pages a day.
Um,
mostly nonfiction.
And whether the book was the little prince or it was something like the wealth
of nations,
you know,
whether it took me an hour or whether it took me eight hours every single day,
I was going to read a hundred pages.
And I did that for years.
Uh,
even when I went back to school in addition to my schoolwork,
I would read a hundred pages.
What came was,
sorry to interrupt,
but what catalyzed that decision?
I mean,
was there a feeling it's like this,
it was this feeling,
I mean psychologically,
you know,
it was like this feeling of being,
maybe behind,
you know,
I,
I remembered,
um,
you know,
the,
one of the very first books that I read was a,
this auto biography of Ben Franklin.
And,
you know,
he has all these kind of,
he did the poor Richard's Almanac and he has all these kinds of sayings.
And I remember,
you know,
first of all,
Ben Franklin himself was kind of the pioneer in and getting self improvement
down to a science.
Do you know what I mean?
And,
um,
so you know,
his example,
first of all,
how much he,
you know,
how much effort he put into improving himself and moving himself forward.
And then I remember he had this one quote,
you know,
that I'm uneducated.
Genius is like finding silver in the mine,
you know,
and it kind of,
it,
it made me think that,
you know,
I had spent all this time kind of,
thinking and kind of pondering,
uh,
and I thought that I was,
you know,
that school was beneath me in school was boring and you know,
because of that I really hadn't been imbibing much information.
And you know,
at that time it's something kind of flipped.
And I felt like,
you know,
I've missed out on,
probably the last four,
six years of education because I was just doing the minimum,
you know,
I was,
I was just getting by and writing my papers before class,
you know,
I was probably looking at the person's next to me,
his paper,
you know,
a few times.
And so it's like,
even though I was making okay grades,
I really wasn't,
you know,
taking in a lot of information and educating myself.
And so,
you know,
I think that at that time I decided I was going to become extremely educated.
And you know,
I did,
I did become an extremely educated person,
but you know,
95% of that education was outside of school.
You know,
95% of that education was over the course of seven or eight years,
uh,
saying I'm going to read 100 pages of nonfiction a day,
every single day.
And I did it for seven or eight years.
I'd say 60% of that was biography.
Uh,
I would say another 20% of it was history.
and then,
you know,
and that wasn't,
I would read fiction too,
you know,
when I was absolutely tired of eating my vegetables,
I,
that's what I,
that's what I would call,
you know,
the most boring books,
the really kind of conceptual one I just viewed as vegetables.
You know,
I was just like sometimes sometimes hard to get through,
but a fiber of knowledge,
you know,
you,
it grows in the kind of,
it kind of develops you.
Um,
but yeah,
you know,
so biographies were the ones that I was really,
really drawn to.
Um,
and so,
you know,
at the time,
I started kind of reading all these biographies and I was loving it and
biographies,
just history.
You know,
biography is the best form of history if you ask me because it cuts through the
theory,
it cuts through,
you know,
all the speculation of the author and we get down to the nuts and the bolts of
the decisions that people made in their lives.
And I think that is the purest form of education that you can get.
And it's the advice that I give people who don't know what they want to do with
their lives.
Pick somebody that you admire and read their biography,
read their biography.
If you really want some sort of guidance in your life,
pick somebody who has done things that you want to do and that you really admire
and read a nice fat 800 page biography of their lives.
Find out the struggles they went through.
Find out the,
you know,
the twists and turns their lives and the decisions they made.
And I mean,
I don't think there's any better actionable roadmap,
actionable education then getting down to the granular level of somebody's life
and finding out how they navigated it.
If,
uh,
if someone wanted to,
let's just say that they are having a lapse of concentration and can't think of
people they admire who have biographies.
If you were to recommend any,
let's just say one to three biographies as Gateway Drugs into that world,
are there any of that comes to mind?
It depends upon what you want to accomplish in life.
Like if you're just flagging and you don't know what you want to do.
A start with Ben Franklin,
start with somebody who was,
who was,
you know,
very disciplined and you know,
programmatic in,
in figuring out how to develop themselves.
Again,
my advice always to people who are stuck is quit looking at the big pictures.
People stuck because they want to accomplish two big things and they don't know
the right step to take.
So,
you know,
I always say just kind of,
instead of focusing on the year,
instead of focusing on the arc of your life,
focus on the 24 hour period and nobody mastered the 24 hour period more than
Benjamin Franklin.
So it's like,
if you have no idea what you want to do,
start there.
I would say if you know what you want to do,
you've got to pick the person that you admired the most.
Do you know,
do you want to participate in social movements?
You know,
Pick Martin Luther King.
Uh,
do you want to be president of the United States?
If you want to pick,
be president of the United States,
I would recommend Lyndon Johnson,
Lyndon Johnson,
because he was probably the president that was given the least in his life,
except for maybe Abraham Lincoln.
You know,
he was the,
he didn't go to Ivy League,
you know,
he didn't,
um,
he wasn't necessarily a,
a great looking guy.
You know,
he went to San Marcos teacher college.
He,
you know,
basically,
and again,
this is if you want to be president,
I don't want to be president.
Uh,
he,
you know,
worked his way up through understanding how the levers of democracy work,
the levers of power in our government work.
Uh,
and so he is a fascinating character sketch on how to be precedent.
if you want to read a Lyndon Johnson biography,
you should read the four volume biography by Robert Caro,
uh,
which is the best of those.
Um,
but you know,
other than that,
it just like,
it all depends upon what it is that you want to do in life.
You know,
there's,
there's just no biography that every person should read.
They should pick the person they admire the most and read the biography of their
life with Ben Franklin.
It would it be the,
uh,
a biography like Walter Isaacson or would be the,
at the Isaac,
the Isaacson one was the one I read and that stands out the most because it was
the first,
the person that I've read the most biographies on properly,
Theodore Roosevelt.
Um,
just because his life is so fascinating.
probably Adolph Hitler,
probably Stalin.
And it's not because it,
in any way these people are admirable.
But like as a history major,
to me it wasn't the individual themself that was fascinating to me.
It was how does a group of people,
you know,
Germany was a smart industrialized country.
To me,
the big philosophical question that fascinated me and the,
and the reason that I,
I've dealt so much into the lives and the practices of dictators is,
you know,
how is it that a group of such educated,
smart,
well meaning people,
uh,
we're,
we're able to be,
you know,
um,
ever to be able to be organized under the,
you know,
the premise of committing such evil.
And that to me as has always fascinated me because I believe that people are
inherently good.
And you know,
I've traveled to 30 or 40 different countries and you know,
it's funny,
every place has a reputation.
Oh,
don't go to this city.
People won't talk to you.
You.
So many times when I land in a place they say,
oh,
this isn't going to work here.
You know,
people,
people aren't open here.
People aren't friendly here.
And,
you know,
I find one on one,
people all over the world,
you know,
are very,
they,
they kind of share,
you know,
a,
a similar soul I guess.
And you know,
if people are generally the same everywhere,
you know,
the,
then that means anywhere something like this could happen anywhere.
You know,
people can,
can get pulled into this crowd psychology and you know,
direct their anger in their hatred and violence towards people in a way that
would counter debt,
their morals if you met them one on one.
And,
you know,
because of that,
the,
the lives in the periods of history that have always been most intellectually
interesting to me.
Again,
it's not something that I admire.
It's not something I am looking to duplicate.
Of course,
uh,
at have been these periods where a very driven ideological individual ads
managed to,
to mobilize a group of people towards ends.
That looking back from a historical perspective were brutal and violent and
absolutely unexplainable.
And you know,
I think it's important to understand these things,
to keep it from happening again.
Do you remember you asked about bond trading?
Like,
oh,
I do.
So no,
I never talked about it.
And
I think,
you know,
I started talking about is cause bond trading was really an anomaly in my life.
Um,
I was really kind of wrapped up in all of these things that we're talking about
now.
You know,
I was really kind of wrapped up and in history and biography mainly.
Um,
when Obama,
uh,
it was,
God,
what was it,
2008,
2007,
I think it was 2007 he was in the primary.
Um,
and I was,
I really became fixated on this campaign.
Uh,
and you know,
I was not,
I was going to knock on doors.
Uh,
and this is during the primary when he's going up against Hillary.
And I was knocking on doors.
I was going to different states,
knocking on doors and,
and,
um,
I was reading every article about the delegate system and super delegates.
And you know,
there's this point where I was just absolutely positive he was going to,
when I was at,
this is the primary,
I was just absolutely positive he was going to win.
Um,
and I was broke at the time on,
this was not something I would ever do today.
Um,
but I took out $5,000 in student loans and I actually bet on Barack Obama,
weird is one bet on something like that.
Back then it was an Irish exchange.
It has since gone under,
it was called Intrade trade.
Um,
and I think they had them at like 40% chance to win at that time.
and he had like a 70% chance you're something.
And so,
you know,
I,
I didn't make a ton of money off of it because it took me like a week to wire my
money to Ireland.
And in the time that I was wiring my money,
he had one,
a couple of minutes.
And so,
um,
you know,
I ended up only making,
I mean I made like,
you know,
a thousand,
$1,200,
which for me as a college student was all the money in the world.
Uh,
but more faithfully,
uh,
I was telling that story just like I'm telling it to you,
to a friend of mine who worked in Chicago and he was a traitor.
He's a bond trader.
And I was telling,
I was telling him that story and he told me,
you know,
the,
the one differentiator between successful traders and unsuccessful traders in
our office is their,
um,
their comfort with risk taking.
Uh,
and based on that story,
um,
you know,
I would like you to talk to my boss.
Um,
and so based on the extreme prudence,
you've demonstrated that story.
Well,
yeah,
it's the,
you know,
I think,
I think it was kind of the,
the comes with risk taking.
And so,
you know,
at that time I was,
I,
I didn't know what I wanted to do.
Again.
I just studied history because I was,
I enjoyed it and I,
uh,
I really enjoyed it.
Um,
and so he got me an interview with his boss and it was scheduled and I mean,
this is somebody who went to an ivy league school and you know,
he had studied finances entire life.
And he had gotten this job.
So I thought this was an opportunity.
I would not have any other way.
And I wasn't sure what I wanted to do at the time.
It was a history major.
Um,
and so I had like a month to prepare,
so I read about 20 books on the market.
Uh,
and then I went into the interview.
And,
uh,
at that time I was very well versed on how markets worked.
And,
uh,
that's how I got that job.
Good thing yet all that reading practice go.
What was your first week as a bond trader?
Like,
um,
well I mean,
and see this is the,
and I always try to say,
you know,
when I,
uh,
mean if somebody that's just listening to this interview up until this point,
you know,
I think it's,
we talk about,
you know,
bond trading and dictators,
which really has nothing to do with my life now.
Um,
but you know,
I,
and,
and I think the narrative that people in interviews always try to put on me is
that I,
cause,
I mean,
it's a fun narrative.
Oh,
chasing the money,
you know,
doing this soul sucking finance job and then,
cut the rope behind him to pursue his true passion,
which was taking photographs and art.
And I mean,
there's a,
there's a kernel of truth there.
Um,
you know,
but the,
the real story is that markets were fascinating to me.
I,
you know,
I'm still fascinated by markets.
You know,
they seem so tangible when you're watching CNBC and you're seeing these numbers
and it seems all so mathematical,
but in reality markets or are nothing but a bunch of people arguing over what
something's worth.
You know,
it's just like,
it's a market.
If you,
if you remove the computer and you know,
go back,
you know,
50 years and market is a crowd of people haggling over what's something that is
impossible to value is worth.
And the,
the,
the number that comes out of it is,
is really based on psychology and it's based on this,
this back and forth over,
over,
you know,
what these numbers mean.
And you know,
that was always so interesting to me.
Um,
and it remains,
you know,
very interesting to me.
So it was philosophically very interested in markets and,
uh,
I was,
I,
I was fascinated by bond trading and,
you know,
I,
I was obsessed with it to be honest,
for two years.
Um,
and it was a type of bond trading.
We were very highly leveraged.
And so,
you know,
it was a time where there was just huge gains,
are huge losses,
like every single night.
Uh,
you know,
I compare it to like playing it very high stakes game of poker every single
night.
And so it was,
it was extremely,
uh,
you know,
I don't think I could do it today.
I was in my early twenties at the time.
It was just,
there's just adrenaline pumping through my body at all times.
And,
you know,
I was in,
in that when you,
when you take something that is your,
you're naturally kind of philosophically interested in it and you pair it with,
um,
you know,
a large amount of money,
uh,
and a large amount of excitement,
it creates this,
this fixation.
It's almost like crack,
you know,
where it's just all you can think about at any given time.
And you know,
when I go to colleges and I give speeches on the path of humans of New York,
and you know,
what led me to kind of pursue this life that was,
you know,
outside of books and outside of computer screens was that,
I,
after the end of two years when I lost my job,
I kind of looked back at,
you know,
the time that I had spent that two years and it,
it wasn't the physical time that was lost that was most concerning to me.
It was that I had spent two years using all of my intellect and all of my
creative energy trying to figure out how to be the most effective relative value
treater in fixed income securities and the Asian markets.
It was something,
it was just something that was so narrow and so myopic and I couldn't even talk
with my friends about it.
And at the end of two years,
you know,
that was,
we'd gone through the financial crisis.
I've lost everything I'd ever made.
You know,
when I,
when I lost that job was a very lucrative job potentially.
But when I lost that job,
I was broke because I lost everything.
Why did you lose the job?
What happened?
Uh,
well,
I mean the,
it,
it depends upon how much personal responsibility I want to take.
You know,
I think the,
the,
the narrative that's most protective of the ego is that we had a type of
treating that was calibrated to work during periods of low volatility.
Um,
the years from I guess 1995 or whatever,
or after,
whenever,
you know,
I don't,
I don't know when my math is right.
But you know,
like late nineties,
two,
you know,
2008 were periods of historically low volatility or the type of training that we
were doing worked.
And during,
when the financial crisis hit in 2008,
volatility went through the roof.
A long story short,
the type of trading that we were doing,
um,
stopped working.
And,
uh,
the company when that had been around for over a decade was out of business,
about a year after I left.
Um,
so that's the,
that is the,
the part of the,
that's the way of explaining that,
that avoids the most personal responsibility.
Um,
if I was to explain it in the way that,
you know,
makes myself the most personally responsible,
uh,
market's changed and I wasn't a adaptive enough to figure it out.
Uh,
I kept banging my head against the same things that used to be working.
I refuse to,
I refuse to fully embrace the fact that what worked for me extremely well for a
year had stopped working.
Uh,
and because of that,
the,
the risk calculations,
it changed and instead of making a lot of money every night,
I was losing a lot of money every night.
Um,
and I eventually got to the point where,
you know,
I,
I was no longer a productive member of the firm.
Uh,
and so yeah,
it depends upon which story you want to tell.
I think the truth is probably somewhere in between the two.
Uh,
but regardless,
I ended without
a job.
Well thank you for telling or sharing both versions of that and no,
it's,
I think that that also reflects a level of,
this may not be the right word,
but sort of objectivity or an ability to detach and observe.
That has always fascinated me,
uh,
about you quite frankly.
Um,
which certainly translates I think in a very empathic way later and we'll,
we'll get to that.
But I want to talk about the finance world and markets for just a second because
as you noted,
it's,
it's very tempting for someone who's trying to weave a narrative of your life
into this soul sucking periods,
sees the light cuts,
the tether,
Burns the ships off into the arts and true passion.
But the,
the markets,
as you noted,
a really fascinating,
and I was chatting with someone,
I've just gotten to know actually in the last few weeks a,
let's call,
suppose you could call them a wealth manager,
but 75% of what he does and is investing in bonds.
He probably wouldn't call it trading,
but in effect,
I mean,
that's,
that's what he's doing.
And he said something to me that that has stuck in my mind for a while now,
which is,
you know,
I learned more in the first two to four hours of sitting down and talking to
someone about money.
Then their therapists have probably learned over the last two to four years and
getting to see how people respond to money and loss aversion and the possibility
of making money is in and of itself.
Fascinating.
Then you add in thousands and millions of market participants,
it gets even more interesting.
And then when,
at least in my limited experience when I read something,
my exposure to bonds is very limited.
But when you read something like Liar's poker,
uh,
by Michael Lewis,
which I think is a fantastic book.
And the part that stuck out to me where I was like,
okay,
I need to be very careful about playing this game because I'll get my face
ripped off is there's some part,
and I'm going to get all the details wrong,
but there's some guy who's nicknamed like fat Tony and he's a big wig at Solomon
brothers.
And he bets his buddies that the markets for whatever,
Aa bonds and x,
y,
and z are going up.
And he said,
he bets them and it's this Dick measuring contest and he puts 50 million into
the market and it,
and it goes down.
And uh,
and so as his friends are busting his balls and he's then they're like,
oh,
market's going up.
Ah,
and so instead of putting 50 million,
and he's like,
fuck it.
And he puts 500 million in like all the other market participants,
panic thinking that he has information they don't.
And so the market goes up and he said,
see,
I told you the market was going up.
And I was like,
oh my God,
this is not nearly as clean as the textbooks would want you to believe.
Well,
I would,
um,
you know,
I,
as somebody who's interviewed 10,000 people,
I would say that,
you know,
talking with somebody about their money and how they choose to use their money,
we'll give you a insight into a very limited,
uh,
a,
an I,
I mean,
maybe,
maybe I'm wrong,
but like a very limited aspect of their personality,
which is their comfort with risk.
And,
uh,
you know,
I think there's,
I think our approach to money and our approach to treating or punched to two
markets are very much kind of driven by like our,
our animal spirits,
you know,
greed and fear and
things like that.
Um,
but,
you know,
I,
I feel that the,
you know,
kind of the,
the,
there's a huge,
a huge portion of people's lives and kind of thought lives that are,
um,
you know,
kind of separate and isolated from,
from that,
those drives,
you know what I mean?
Those,
those very kind of primal drives of wanting,
wanting more and being afraid to lose.
I mean,
that's,
that's really what drives the markets is,
is the,
is the greed and the fear is,
and I,
you know,
I think,
I think talking with somebody about their,
you know,
their,
those,
those two drives and where their greed comes from or where their fear comes
from,
you know,
it'll,
it'll give you,
it'll give you some insight.
But,
you know,
I,
they know,
to me,
the,
the markets,
you know,
they,
there's,
they can only tell you so much.
Um,
and they can only,
you know,
it's such a,
it's,
it's a part of human existence.
The,
the,
the drives that,
that control a market.
Um,
but,
you know,
there's so much that people care about outside of that.
And I think that was what was so dangerous about just being a trader is that,
you know,
you're,
you're bearing so much of your thought energy into just the desire for more and
the fear of losing,
you know what I mean?
That kind of the kind of narrow,
animalistic drives that,
that you know,
that,
that push market ups up and down and you're kind of tethering yourself to that,
uh,
and you just kind of miss out on so much of the life that's going on around you.
And this is me.
You know,
this is me.
I think it's part of my personality that once I dive into something,
it's,
I do it to the exclusion of almost everything else.
Uh,
one of the reasons humans of New York,
uh,
ended up becoming so successful.
Uh,
I did know,
you know,
some,
uh,
you know,
miss more the exception than the rule.
There are people who are so in control of their emotions or maybe they don't
have the same emotional range as other people,
um,
that are able to turn off their computer every single day,
go home and not think about the markets and come kind of completely leave them
there.
Um,
but you know,
for me it was something that,
you know,
was kind of all consuming for me.
And you know,
I made the
decision to pursue something more artistic,
um,
was when,
you know,
I had kind of,
I had kind of lost my job and I was looking back at the two years of my life and
I was thinking,
God,
you know,
and,
and after I lost my job,
you know,
I,
I was so scared of that day,
you know,
during the two years when I was obsessing over markets and then things started
going bad,
you know,
there was nothing I was more afraid of than losing that job.
And then on the day that it happened,
it was surprisingly a good day because I remember taking a walk that day and I
started asking myself things like,
what do I want to do?
You know,
like what,
what do I want to do?
Things?
Something like if I could do anything with my time,
what would I do?
And I had,
I had been for two years,
like so focused on keeping that job,
you know,
that I had,
I,
I had never,
I didn't have room in my brain to kind of ask myself any other questions.
And so,
you know,
at that moment I decided,
I've lost these two years of not only my time,
but more importantly,
I've lost two years of my thoughts focusing on this,
this,
this game,
this game for making money,
which was fascinating and philosophically interesting.
But you know,
when you,
when you boil it down,
it's a game.
And I said,
you know,
I'm going to spend the next foreseeable future instead of my spending my time
trying to make money.
You know,
I'm going to try to make just enough money to where I can control my time and
just do something that I enjoy doing for no other reason,
then it is nourishing in the moment.
Not that at the end of the day I'm going to have a profit,
but because it's nourishing in the moment.
And at that time it was photography and the whole reason I think you don't want
of the best,
you know,
the kind of the neatest things about humans of New York is that over the past
eight years,
you know,
humans of New York has become largely,
the most,
you know,
followed photography project in the world with 25 million on social media now.
And it's eight years old.
And I think one of the coolest things is I just started photographing about
eight years ago.
You know,
I started taking photos during this time that I'm talking with you about.
And the whole reason I started taking photos was because I was trying to create
some space in my mind away from work.
I was desperate for something to do on the weekends that,
you know,
d that would,
would give me this,
this foot hold in my brain where I had a sense of purpose and he sense of
identity outside how the markets were doing every single day.
And so I bought this camera,
I started going to downtown and photographing,
you know,
just everything.
Uh,
and I loved it.
And not long after I lost my job and I made the decision that I was going to be
a photographer,
not because I was very skilled at it at the time,
you know,
not because I thought it was an angle towards success and not because I thought
it was an angle towards an audience is that I just loved doing it in the moment.
It was nourishing in the moment.
And so I found this thing that was nourishing in the moment that I enjoyed
doing.
And I said,
you know,
I'm going to try to structure my life around creating as much time for this as
possible.
I want to make the minimum amount of,
I just,
I want to make just enough money to where I can pay my rent,
eat and photograph all day long.
And the journey that ended up creating humans of New York was my attempt to
create that space in my life and that space in my head to focus on something
that was very nourishing in the moment.
How did you cover your expenses in the very early days of that experience?
This was 2008.
Um,
we had a,
I believe
a record amount of time that you could get unemployment and I had just lost my
job.
And so I got $620,
I think every two weeks,
uh,
from the government because I was unemployed and I had worked for two years.
Um,
so that was enough to basically just pay my rent in a sublease that I found on
craigslist,
uh,
and Bedford Stuyvesant Brooklyn,
that was enough to pay that and maybe have peanut butter jelly sandwiches and
eggs.
I'm assuming that you need to know other expenses that you wore the same
clothes,
the same shoes.
That was enough for me to just eat,
sleep and photograph all day long.
Um,
and once I got to have a,
you know,
a decent level of skill and I mean,
just a passable level of skill,
uh,
if anybody would pay me to take portraits for them,
I would do that.
I,
somebody hired me to do their wedding.
Um,
and,
uh,
I basically,
I just,
I didn't spend money on anything.
All I did was photograph all day long because I knew that I was like,
I was making this pivot in my life to where I was going after kind of a
lucrative career towards,
I was going towards just wanting to spend my time doing something all day long.
Uh,
and so,
you know,
and I became obsessed with photography in the same way that I was obsessed with
markets.
I mean,
I just,
I loved it.
I just loved it.
It was like a treasure hot.
I mean,
just going out and was so different than trading too.
it was,
I'm outside,
I'm interacting with the world,
I'm having conversations,
you know,
I'm having these little adventures,
discovering these new things,
and I was just hooked on it and I was just obsessed with it.
And you know,
I knew I was making a lot of sacrifices to be doing this in my life.
Uh,
so I didn't do anything else.
You know,
I didn't go to concerts.
I didn't go out to restaurants.
I really,
I didn't spend much time with friends because I didn't really know anybody in
New York.
Uh,
I mean,
that's another crazy detail about humans of New York is that humans of New York
is an eight year old photography project.
Uh,
you know,
based on people in New York City.
Uh,
you know,
I took my first foot photograph eight years ago and I went to New York for the
very first time in my life eight years ago.
Uh,
so it was,
you know,
all,
it was all just a very new and all very driven by the desire to photograph all
day long.
Was the move to New York related to the desire to take photographs or was it
something else?
So,
I mean,
what I did is,
so I got fired,
uh,
and I started,
my goal was I got it.
I want to find out how to be a photographer.
You know,
I love photography.
How am I going to create a life where I can support myself and photograph all
day long?
And so I was just out doing it every single day.
And then I started kind of along with the graffiti and along with the
architectural shots and along with the nature shots,
I started photographing people and I noticed that these,
out of everything I was photographing,
the photographs of people were the most unique.
They're the ones that that least resembled everything else I was seeing being
put on Facebook and stuff like that.
Um,
and so I decided to kind of focus on that.
And then while focusing on that,
I started stopping people on the street and asking for their photo and kind of
taking a portrait of them.
And because of that extra layer of difficulty of having to approach a stranger,
the portrait.
So that was taking of people were more different than the candid photos I was
taking of people.
And so I started focusing solely on that,
you know,
and that's when I kind of started having an idea that even though I hadn't been
photographing so long,
I was heading in a direction that was pretty unique because I was stopping
random people on the streets.
Um,
in a very,
you know,
I know some people will do series,
but I was doing this every single day and I was getting quite a collection and
this seems like kind of a new kind of fresh type of photography.
So it's all I did.
And then I started traveling to different cities.
I went to Philadelphia just stopping people.
Then I went to New Orleans.
Um,
I went back to Atlanta and did this and then I traveled to New York and when I
got to New York and I was stopping people and asking for their photographs,
um,
I realized that New York,
if you were going to try to do this type of photography was the best place to
be.
I mean,
mainly just,
just practical reasons,
uh,
that you,
you don't need a car in New York.
I didn't have a car.
Um,
and I couldn't afford a car.
You,
uh,
you can just ride the subway everywhere.
You can walk everywhere.
And there's so many people.
I mean,
there's so many people.
I remember coming out of the Lincoln tunnel the very first time and looking down
and I couldn't even see the sidewalk.
Let's rush.
It was rush hour and that it was just,
there were so many people and I thought,
you know,
if I'm going to do this type of photography,
uh,
this is the place to do it.
And I wasn't doing any interviews at this time.
And I mean that's,
that's the thing,
it's like the humans of New York that I moved to New York to do looks nothing
like the humans of New York that later became successful.
I mean,
it was really just the impetus to get me on the ground working every day to kind
of figure it out along the way.
Uh,
you know,
my very first idea for humans of New York was I was going to photograph 10,000
people in New York City across all five boroughs and I was going to plot their
photo on a map.
That was my idea of how I was going to make a life out of being a photographers.
I was going to be the guy who did that.
And,
uh,
it was,
that was kind of what got me on the grounds,
got me out on the street every single day,
approaching hundreds and thousands of people,
uh,
and put me in the situation where I could kind of innovate and I could start
having conversations with these people,
which turned into questions I was asking them,
which turned into eventually seven years later,
the kind of 90 minute to an hour and a half long,
very kind of probing and,
and therapeutic and,
and psychological interviews that I have with random strangers every single day.
The result of which,
and the output of which,
uh,
became the stories that I think people are so connected with and the stories
that really make humans of New York humans of New York.
How are you getting better at photography,
uh,
during this say first,
let's just call it six month period.
Since you certainly seem from all indications to be someone who goes for total
immersion and whether it's reading 10 to 20 books,
the market before an interview,
uh,
you go 100% into whatever subject matter you choose.
How are you getting better?
What books were you reading?
Who are you studying?
What were you trying,
I mean I was too addicted to taking photos to ever stop for a second and learn
about photography.
I have,
I have one memory.
I have one memory of going to Barnes and noble cause I going to afford to buy
any books.
Uh,
I have one memory of going to Barnes and noble one night and flipping through
some photography books and,
and enjoying the photos.
But uh,
I just,
I,
I just wanted to be out taking pictures.
You know,
I,
I didn't really want to be studying how to take a correct photo,
you know,
I just wanted to be out photographing.
It was the,
the act of it,
the act of discovery,
you know,
and I had a very amateur view of photography at the time.
Where is if you,
if you get something or somebody interesting in the frame,
it's a great photo.
I don't care how many points perspective it has.
I don't care about the rules of thirds.
I honestly don't really even care about white balance or focus or any of these
things.
I was just looking for,
for wonderful people and wonderful moments that were happening.
I was still doing a lot of candid photography of people.
Uh,
and if I,
if I captured that,
that was a good photo and that's,
that's all I cared about.
And that was what was driving me for these,
you know,
these first several months and this first year,
year and a half when I took thousands and thousands of pictures and I was
getting better slowly.
I mean,
I'm,
I'm not necessarily bragging about that kind of aversion to formal training as
if it was some sort of badge of honor.
It was just the way my psychology was hardwired and because of that I might have
improved more slowly than somebody else.
And in fact,
I might've been proved so slowly that I'm sure a lot of professional
photographers look down on my photography still.
But by being that engaged and emerged in the process as opposed to any sort of a
formal structure of what makes a photograph,
I innovated my own style.
I innovated my own type of work that leader on,
you know,
people have introduced me to studs Terkel and people introduced me to,
to these,
these,
these wonderful photographers to the past who took these,
you know,
Jacob Reese who took these wonderful photos of regular people,
uh,
that my work,
you know,
kind of grew to resemble.
But I mean,
any resemblance just came out of being on the street and doing it all day long
and just,
and,
and figuring out,
you know,
what it was that I
liked the most and without any education of what it correct photograph was.
And that,
you know,
I think if humans of New York has original elements,
if humans of New York is original in any way,
it was because I was just so addicted to taking photos that I never stopped to
learn about photography.
And because of that,
you know,
I,
I just,
I was figuring out as I went on,
well,
it seems to me also that there are many different facets of photography.
One component of which is the technical knowledge,
but certainly another component of which is choosing the subject matter.
Right.
And thinking about the story that an image tells.
So you were learning about photography,
but you were doing at visa vi the sheer volume of experience that you were
gathering behind the camera and walking through New York City.
Right.
Well,
I was just,
you know,
I was looking for anyone who,
anything that captured my attention or curiosity at all got photographed.
I mean,
and that's one of the beautiful things about digital cameras is,
you can just take a thousand photos every single day.
Um,
and so you don't have to worry about conserving film.
Like you can just photograph everything.
And so anything that caught my eye got photographed.
And then when you go home,
when you load your thousand pictures on the computer and you start going through
and because you don't know how to photograph,
you photograph that person 50 different times and you're looking at your 50
photos of each person and you're finding the one that you think looks the best,
and then you're going and you're doing it again and you're doing it again,
and suddenly you're not taking 50 photos of each person.
You're taking 40 even 30 then 20 and then 10 as you start to get an idea of what
it is that you think is a great photo and what it is that you like.
Uh,
and that was kind of really how I was honing in on my style again,
which might still be considered primitive.
It's still might be considered unschooled by a lot of people,
but I was just honing in on what I liked about a photo.
Um,
and that's,
that was the process.
What were you,
what were you doing with these photos in the,
in the beginning,
or maybe a better question is when you first started putting photos online,
what did that look like?
Um,
at first I was putting the,
I had one of my main kind of weaknesses and blind spots in the beginning was not
understanding the importance of daily content because,
you know,
I had never had a blog before.
Um,
and so I kind of had this great,
and I mean it kind of mirrors my,
my journey as a college student where I was like trying to do something huge
instead of focusing on doing something every single day.
Um,
and so I was,
I had this huge kind of sweeping project of I was going to photograph 10,000
people and plot their photos on a map.
I was dumping about 30 or 40 of these
portraits every single day onto this website that I had that nobody was going to
and the numbers,
I even had a counter on the top of the website counting,
counting up to 10,000 because that's all I cared about was the end.
I was going to get 10,000,
I was going to create this sweeping photography project.
Um,
was it called humans of New York at the time or what was it called?
It was called humans of New York from the very beginning.
Yes.
Um,
and it things really and,
and nobody was really paying attention and I was taking hundreds and thousands
of portraits and things really started to get traction when I started posting
the photos as I got them on to social media,
mainly Facebook.
That is when things really started to grow and the focus of humans of New York
moved away from this giant sweeping project of that was going to cover the
entire city of New York and be some sort of representation of New York City.
And it's switched to much more too about the individual who is this person that
I'm meeting each day.
And it became something more personal and immediate.
Uh,
and that's when things really started growing.
Brendan,
I'd love to ask you about the green lady.
If that rings a bell.
Could you please describe for folks the experience of the Green Lady?
So,
I mean,
I'm in New York and I've been trying to make this work,
uh,
for bounce six months now.
And six months in that time of my life was probably the equivalent,
about two years of work,
uh,
because I worked every single day.
I worked on Christmas or worked on Thanksgiving.
Um,
I didn't go home.
All I did would just photograph all day long.
You know,
I would go out,
I would,
I would just photograph people had come home,
I would take a nap and then I would go out at night,
uh,
and try to get some more photos.
And so I had gotten thousands of these portraits and not many people were paying
attention.
I think I had just kind of started posting my photos on Facebook and,
um,
I photographed this woman and she was dressed all in green and she had green
hair and green makeup.
And I remember it was a,
it was a photo that I,
I didn't like,
I thought it was a very bad photo and I wasn't even going to really posted on
the blog.
Uh,
but then I remembered that she had said something to me.
She had said,
I used to be a different color every single day,
but then one day I was green and that was a great day.
And so I've been green for 15 years
and
I,
I remember thinking to myself,
well,
I don't really like the photograph,
uh,
but I'm going to try putting this quote above it that she said,
and I posted onto Facebook and suddenly it was the most engaged with photo that
I'd ever posted.
Uh,
I think we're talking like 67 likes at this time.
There was not a lot of people following my page.
Um,
and it really,
it was kind of a Eureka moment because it really made sense that,
you know,
and this,
during these months and almost a year of doing nothing but approaching random
people on the street and asking for their photograph.
Uh,
the thing that strangely I had gotten to be an expert at wasn't the photography,
but it was the approaching strangers and the,
the walking up to random people,
uh,
getting rejected a lot of times and not letting that affect my,
my mood.
Uh,
and then once meeting somebody,
you know,
in a very short amount of time,
making that person comfortable and kind of the Eureka moment was if that is what
I've become good at,
if that is what I have to offer the world,
shouldn't I,
now that I've gotten over this fear of approaching a stranger,
use that opportunity to learn a little bit about this person so that I can share
a little bit about this person with other people who might be curious of the
people around them but haven't been able to overcome that fear of talking to
strangers.
And you know,
it turned out that the audience for that,
the,
the amount of people who were curious with the lives of the people around them
but were too afraid to ask,
uh,
you know,
ended up being hundreds,
then thousands and then tens of thousands and millions.
And then now tens of millions.
And you know,
from that moment on,
humans of New York stops being a photography project.
Uh,
I don't even view myself as a photographer.
You know,
you can,
you can write a three page essay about why I'm a horrible photographer and it's
been done many times.
Uh,
and it doesn't really bother me because I stopped viewing myself as a
photographer a long time ago.
Uh,
the photography's really secondary to humans of New York.
You know,
humans of New York is my effort in a short of time as possible to make a person
on the street comfortable enough and seeing that it seemed like somebody's
interested enough in their lives that they'll share their story with me and
they'll share something deep and vulnerable and real and honest about their
lives so that I can share that with millions of people every single night.
Uh,
and humans of New York over the past six years has been my effort to get as good
at that as possible.
This,
this is a perfect segue to asking about the approaches and questions,
which is
Richards is a really important thing.
I've spent the entire,
I feel guilty cause I spent the entire,
if you look,
I have not posted a picture of myself on humans of New York in years.
Uh,
I don't,
I don't do it.
Uh,
I find I find that humans of New York is best when I'm the most invisible.
I feel that the,
the less humans of New York is about Brandon Stanton,
the more influential humans of New York has become.
Um,
so yeah,
it's,
uh,
it feels very unnatural to have spent an hour talking already and talk nothing
about myself.
So please
fire away,
ask about the work.
So I'm going to ask about the work and you can,
uh,
you can talk about yourself in third person if it makes it feel better,
but I will have to,
I will have to involve you in this,
uh,
when,
what do you say when you cold approach someone on the street?
Uh,
assuming that now of course you could use humans of New York and a lot of people
would recognize it and you could break the ice that way,
but it early on when nobody would recognize that.
How,
how did you,
how did you open and then w what did you use to break the ice and the first 60
seconds,
uh,
first thing always is,
do you mind if I take your photograph?
Um,
that was the first thing.
And I mean,
these are all little things I learned is you don't walk up to somebody and ask,
do you have a minute?
Do you know?
Because that immediately puts somebody on defensive because in,
especially in New York City,
so people were walking up to you all day long trying to sell you something,
asking for money.
So people are naturally very defensive.
Um,
so I don't want my,
my goal is to get into it as soon as possible too.
So people realize that this is something a little bit different and I'm not
looking to for their money.
That's the main thing.
You know,
I'm not looking for their money.
Um,
so I normally walk up and I say,
uh,
do you mind if I take your photograph?
Um,
I run a website called humans of New York and basically what I do is over the
past several years,
I photographed about 10,000 people on the streets of New York City and around
the world.
And I just learned a little bit about everyone I photograph.
Um,
and so I was just wondering if I could take your photo and ask you a few
questions.
Okay.
Now before you had the 10,000 and went around the world when it was maybe the
hundredth person or 200th person,
was it the same pitch minus that stuff?
I was trying to give you actually the pitch that I used to give in the early
days.
Now I pull out my cell phone to number one,
New York Times bestselling books.
Um,
you know,
20 million followers on Facebook.
And the whole reason of that,
even though it kind of sounds like boastful and braggy,
is that especially if somebody hasn't heard of humans of New York,
you know,
I want to convince them in as short amount of time as possible.
Um,
that is,
it's something real.
One that's important.
Um,
and that it's something that,
you know,
is a lot of people know about and a lot of people follow.
It's not a joke.
It's not a prank.
You're not going to be embarrassed.
You're not gonna,
you know,
my goal is in as short amount of time as possible to kind of,
make the person feel comfortable.
And these days,
a big part of that is kind of explaining how big the block is because then it's,
then it's like,
oh,
this person is not trying to hustle me.
This person isn't trying to scam me.
Um,
but you know,
to be honest,
you know,
in the early days,
my success,
you know,
the amount of people who let me take their photo wasn't that much less.
Um,
except back then,
I wasn't a best selling author.
I was just a kid.
Um,
you know,
who was,
trying to make an art project and,
and you know,
people wanted to help.
And so,
you know,
the,
I think a lot of people think that,
you know,
one of the reasons so many people are willing to talk to me is because humans of
New York is so well known,
especially in New York now.
Uh,
but,
you know,
I,
the,
my,
uh,
my rate of people who would talk to me was not all that different when I was
just getting started.
Are there any other nonverbal cues to that?
I mean,
there's tons of them and,
but I mean,
again,
these aren't things that I like,
Aye.
I,
these aren't things that,
you know,
I planned or read about.
You know,
it's not that I get a lot of trial and error.
Well,
they were,
they were burned into me by being rejected so much.
And,
you know,
some rejections on the streets of New York aren't always polite.
You know what I mean?
It was hard,
you know,
in the early days.
I mean,
I remembered there were days,
the hardest part about it was,
I mean,
especially when I got started in humans of New York,
didn't have any fans and it wasn't book.
It's,
you know,
it wasn't made into any books.
And me know,
my family didn't believe in it and my friends thought I was crazy.
I had no photography experience.
I'm in New York City,
you know,
stopping random people and asking them questions and I'm feeling insecure.
And you know,
I,
when you walk up to somebody and you ask them if they can your photo and they
respond like you're some sort of freak or that you're weird,
you know,
it's,
it's hard to not internalize that because you're so insecure at the moment
about,
you know,
whether or not what you're doing is weird.
And if it's something that,
that,
you know,
it am I,
am I weird,
you know,
for,
for asking these people for their,
for their photographs and you know,
I go out some days and 10 people in a row would make me feel like I'm some sort
of freak.
Like,
do you know what city you're in?
You can't be stopped and rid of people,
like,
get out of my way,
get what you,
what are you doing?
Like,
no,
you can't take my photo,
like,
get Outta here.
You know what I mean?
And like during my formative and like impressionable,
you know,
early days when I'm trying to figure this out,
five reactions like that in a row when nobody's paying attention to your work
and you've been trying for months and you can't figure it out.
I mean,
psychologically it was very tough.
And you know,
there'd be days where that would happen.
I would just kind of do it anymore and I would just go home and,
and,
you know,
lay in bed.
Uh,
yeah,
yeah.
Oh,
well,
I mean,
it's just like the,
that was,
that's the hardest part about doing it.
Uh,
what,
what did you,
what did you say?
I mean,
what would you say to yourself during a period like that?
it sounds so,
to me at least,
I mean the picture that is painting,
having,
uh,
experienced some dark periods in my life had been maybe catalyzed by various
things.
It sounds really soul crushing.
I mean,
that sounds really,
oh,
it's just,
that was all,
you know,
like that was all,
it was all like,
you know,
all of the doubt and you know,
all those and not having any money,
you know,
nobody's paying attention and it,
I'm just doing this all day long for months and you know,
like all the tough shit was,
uh,
and like the loneliness too.
Like I didn't know anybody in New York.
Like there was like,
I knew like two people and cars and you know,
like there was a Christmas break where those two people went home.
And like for two weeks I didn't see anybody that I knew.
Uh,
Jesus.
Yeah.
And you know,
I remember,
I,
you know,
was I spent Christmas Eve alone and diner.
Um,
and then I just went out and photographed,
you know,
cause it was just like the only thing,
it was the thing
that could like that would keep me from like thinking about how unlikely it was
and you know,
whether,
how,
how stupid of an idea it might be.
Like the only thing that,
that I think,
you know,
kept me from thinking about the possibility of failing was doing,
it was just photographing.
And so like whenever I started to to think,
is this gonna work?
Is it not going to work?
Uh,
I just go out and photograph.
You know,
I,
that was my only way of like keeping those wolves away of,
you know,
is this ultimately going to be a success?
Am I wasting my time?
And in my,
in my,
my stupid like a,
the only way to keep those away was to go out and work and you know,
and so that's what I would do just all day long and do it and do it and do it.
And so like these negative things,
like the rejection of people and you know,
people saying no.
Then I was talking about like all of the negative stuff.
Like the thing that was like counteracting that all the time was just loving it
so much.
You know,
I just,
I just loved it so much.
Uh,
and
so yeah,
you know,
it's like,
it was just kind of this,
this is the same way I was obsessed with markets.
You know,
I was obsessed with taking photos.
Uh,
and so that's kind of what carried me through at all.
I mean,
listening to this story,
it makes me want to ask you,
when I look at humans of New York and think about how many thousands of people
you've humanized and how much empathy you've created traveling to other
countries,
helping to paint a more complete picture of humanity instead of allowing sort of
mass media distortion to create us versus them mentality or counteracting that
at least to a very real degree in helping millions of people who have been
exposed to your work and the interviews to feel less alone.
I mean,
are you,
that's a huge fucking deal.
And I,
I,
it just,
it pains me to hear a story like this,
but it's so helpful for you to share it because I wonder how many people have
ended up like in that diner alone and just quit.
Right?
They just stop.
I mean,
well,
I mean it's not even,
it's not even about stopping,
you know,
it's just like,
I think humans of New York work,
it's not about like goals are like mission or,
you know,
I had a goal and I had a mission,
but people just feel alone,
period.
You know?
I mean it's like that's,
that's why humans of New York as I succeeded,
and I'm not even talking about the people reading it.
I mean,
the number one question that people ask me is how do you get people to share
with you?
And you know,
I think,
you know,
for,
for most people,
they're not just,
if you follow humans of New York,
you know,
like I was yesterday,
I was talking with a woman who,
I mean,
she had not heard of humans of New York.
This is a perfect example.
You know,
I,
she was catching a train.
She had 30 minutes.
She had never heard of humans of New York.
We start out with me kind of showing her the blog and 30 minutes later the
police that we ended up at was,
she was in this purgatory where her husband was depressed and an alcoholic and
he wasn't doing anything that was ultimately so bad.
He didn't beat her,
he didn't cheat on her,
but she wasn't getting fulfilled.
And she was wondering if she was living her best life by staying with him for
the kids.
And she came to this place where she admitted that she was kind of secretly
hoping that he would do something bad to make the decision easier on her and
like that sort of like honesty and that sort of truth and that sort of rawness.
I mean,
I don't know if she even admitted that to herself before and you know,
people ask me and that happens all the time,
Tim,
like that's good humans of New York.
I mean,
some of it's just,
you know,
pictures of kids say and cute stuff and some of it's cute couples,
talking about their relationship.
But you know,
good,
good humans of New York is,
is when we get to that moment,
you know,
when me and somebody or thinking through something or talking through something
that they might not have,
have thought through before and you know,
the way people say,
how do you get there with a complete stranger?
You know,
I think that whenever I'm talking to somebody on the street,
there are two threads running through their head at any given time.
And one of them is this kind of fear of being exposed,
this feeling of,
of being vulnerable and discomfort.
Who is this guy?
Like,
why is he asking me these questions?
And on the other hand there this appreciation of being heard that even though I
don't know this guy,
this is the first person who has taken such a,
a focused and detailed interest in my problems and,
and,
and of the feeling of having somebody focused.
So an intensely not on the sports teams you like or the music you like or any of
the other kind of trivial things that we,
we,
we get,
we get asked it on it on a daily basis.
But you know,
these,
these real things that you're struggling with and maybe not even on the top of
your mind,
but like at the back of your mind that you're not even really bringing to the
surface.
You know,
being heard like that is such a validating thing that that's why people always
share and,
and I tell people at the beginning of every interview that these questions are
going to be hard and anything you don't want to answer,
you don't have to answer.
And we talk about when they got molested as a child,
we talk about them cheating on their husbands.
We talk about their alcoholism.
We,
we talk about how they don't love their child as much as they expected they
would.
You know,
we talk about all these things and almost never do.
People say,
I don't want to talk about that.
And I think the reason humans of New York works isn't because the people who are
reading it feel alone.
That's a big part of it is that people,
when they see somebody being vulnerable in a way that they're afraid to be
vulnerable themselves,
they connect with that person.
But it really works because the people on the street that I meet are so thankful
to have somebody really listened to them
that in that bubble and an hour and a half where I'm sitting with a stranger on
the street,
this magic happens where they're willing to kind of let me into a space in their
mind or their soul or whatever it is that they don't really let other people
into.
And it's,
it's that place that I think connects with so many people.
That's an incredible gift slash talent that you've developed that allows you to
make people comfortable enough to open up to that extent in 30 minutes.
I mean,
that is incredibly impressive to me.
Uh,
even given the fact that perhaps one of the elements underpinning it is how,
how heard they feel,
which is absolutely,
I'm sure the case.
Uh,
I think about questions a lot and you have much more experience than I do and
that just blows me away that you're able to get there in such a short period of
time.
What are some of the other ingredients or aspects of it that help you to
questions perhaps that help?
It's,
it's not the questions I have about three or four entry questions that I use.
What's your biggest struggle?
How your life turned out differently than you expected it to.
What do you feel most guilty about?
But really the planned questions are just kind of springboards into a
conversation.
And you know where how you get to that deep place with a person is absolute
presence.
It's being 100% there.
You're not thinking in the framework of an interview.
You're not looking at a list of questions.
You're not thinking about your next question.
You're not thinking about how this person fits into your idea of them and what
you know about them.
You're 100% there and you're 100% listening to them and your questions are 100%
coming based on curiosity about what they are telling you and nothing else.
And you know why it is that I think humans of New York is special and I think
humans of New York is,
is something that you know,
is,
is precious and may be difficult to replicate is that,
you know,
I've spent seven years in these conversations with 10,000 people and it's not
necessarily that I have gotten so good at asking questions,
it's just that I've gotten so comfortable in the presence of a stranger and so
comfortable in the presence of somebody that I've just met that I can sit there
with them without an ounce of self consciousness and just be,
and just be there with it and listened to them and be curious about them.
And there's this energy that happens there that this doesn't feel like somebody
that's interviewing you.
It feels like somebody who knows you and cares about you is really interested in
what's going on in your life.
And I,
and it's,
it's very subtle and hard to describe,
but I think it's that energy and that presence in that being there and it's
something I had to earn.
It's the same thing like public speaking,
you know?
I mean,
when do you really get good at public speaking?
It's when you've done it so much that you can be yourself on the stage yet and
there's only one way to get there and that's to be on stage,
scare to shit over and over and over and over and over and over and over again.
And I think the only way to get to that place where you can have that rapport
with a stranger is not by studying interview techniques.
It's by sitting with thousands and thousands and thousands and thousands of
strangers until nothing feels strange about it anymore.
And you're able to be in that calm,
present place.
And what happens is your energy transfers the other person
and they get to that place too.
If we were to pick up the example that you gave just a few minutes ago about
this woman talking about her relationship with her husband and his depression
and alcoholism and so on.
How did you,
if,
if you remember,
how did you end up there in,
in other words,
do you recall how the conversation headed to that point?
Yeah,
I mean it can,
uh,
well let me give you another example since I already,
let me give me an example of somebody I talked to in the Philippines a few weeks
ago.
Same thing.
I've traveled to 30 different countries now.
I've done the exact same work.
I've been to Pakistan,
I've been to Iran,
I've been to Iraq,
uh,
and I work with interpreters and the process is exactly the same.
I just walk up to people,
random people,
and getting into these conversations with them.
There was a woman in a park in the Philippines and I started asking her,
I think one of the first questions I asked her was,
what is your biggest goal in life?
And she said she wanted to have a good family life.
And so I thought that that was the story.
And I started asking about that and I learned that she wanted to have a good
family life because when she was young,
her family split and she was forced to go to the courthouse with her mom and her
dad at the age of nine.
And the judge made her choose which parents she wanted to go with.
Yeah.
And so I thought that was the story.
And so I started asking questions about that.
And then I learned that she ended up going with her mom and afterwards she,
her mom remarried and she didn't like her new stepfather.
So she ran away.
And I thought that that was the story.
So I started asking questions about that.
And then I found out that the reason she ran away was because her step father
was abusing her and that she had never told a person in her life,
including her mom until that moment that that had happened.
And that's how we end up in those places is I just,
I am just curious about what's going on in there.
You know,
I'm just curious about what happened.
I,
I want to know the story and I just ask and I asked,
can I ask?
And if something's not quite making sense,
I want to know why.
And so I ask more and I ask boring.
And it's,
it's like you can't,
I mean,
somebody can choose to eventually to not tell the truth by saying I'm
uncomfortable with it,
but it can't really be concealed if somebody is really,
really,
really curious,
you know what I mean?
Why he can never,
you know,
get to the point like it's humans of New York interviews don't work.
I always say it's not because somebody doesn't have an interesting story.
Humans of New York interviews don't work.
When I reached a place,
when somebody's uncomfortable with the process,
which is absolutely fine,
there's,
that's completely understandable.
I'm a random person.
I'm sharing these stories with 20 million people.
It's 100% fine if you don't want to share.
Like that's not,
that is,
that is nothing against you at all.
But those are the interviews that don't make it on the blog.
It's not that people aren't interesting.
It's that humans of New York really kind of thrives on this kind of honesty.
And if somebody is willing to be honest,
I mean everybody's got an interesting story and so it's like the,
I hit dead ends not because somebody is boring,
it's because somebody isn't comfortable with disclosing.
Um,
and so that's,
that's kind of what defines,
you know,
the,
the humans of New York interview or what is usable,
the humans of New York interview.
How often when people disclose,
when they do go there and disclose these very vulnerable stories or things
they've never told anyone else,
how often do they ask that you not use it or that they are or express concern
that it's going to cause some type of problem for them?
Well,
that's,
that's one thing that I am very principled about.
Um,
I give the person agency every step of the way.
I tell them anything you don't want to ask.
First of all,
they don't have to talk to me.
Okay.
They have that decision.
Once we start talking,
I say,
any question you don't want to answer,
you don't have to answer.
If you tell me something during the course of this interview and you change your
mind afterwards,
it don't want me to share it.
That's fine.
At the end of the interview,
if you would like me to photograph your hands or your feet instead of your face,
we can do that.
In fact,
if it's a very vulnerable story,
I will normally insist on that to protect the person or protect somebody that
they're talking about.
If after I've done the interview and before it's posted at anytime you change
your mind and you don't want me to share it,
I give them my email address and after the photo is up for any reason,
at any time,
if you become uncomfortable from all the attention and would like me to take the
story down,
I immediately will.
And so people have control of it every step of the way.
Uh,
it's very important to me that nobody ever sees humans of New York as something
that was done to them.
I always want it to be seen as something that was done with them and you know,
have I failed at that?
Sometimes out of the 10,000 people have I interviewed,
you don't have there been people who were,
didn't expect me to share a certain part of their story or were surprised by it
or it was a negative experience for,
there have been a handful,
you know,
but I can only say that those are the,
those are the worst moments for me.
Uh,
when humans of New York was a negative experience for somebody,
cause that's who I really care about is,
is the people that,
that are on the blog,
you know,
that because I mean they're,
they're the people who kind of,
I had that moment with,
you know,
I spent an hour and a half with them and we,
and we got to that place and you know,
I just,
if they are hurt by it,
you know what I mean?
Um,
or if it's like,
if,
especially if they were really kind of vulnerable,
then that's,
that's when I feel the worst about myself.
Uh,
because I know how much pressure that spotlight can be.
And I know,
you know,
how,
how difficult it can be.
You know,
under,
you know,
having 20 million people look at you.
And so,
you know,
if,
if I,
if I ever feel that,
like I maybe accidentally misrepresented it or,
or,
you know,
or that,
that's,
that's when I feel the worst.
How do you think about
money as it relates to humans of New York?
Uh,
ostensibly you want to probably eat more than peanut butter and jelly sandwiches
and eggs now at the same,
yeah.
Yeah.
Go ahead.
And I'm just going to say in terms of what you do with advertising or
partnerships or projects,
because you have such also such sensitive,
not,
not always,
but
you have such potentially sensitive subject matter and it's so personalized for
these folks or any cases.
How do you,
how do you think about that?
Right.
Um,
well the,
you know,
right now,
obviously,
so humans of New York,
I think we sold a million and a half books.
Um,
the,
you know,
the television show,
Facebook,
you know,
there's more than one person interested in it.
And Facebook,
you know,
they,
they compensated me well for the four years of work that I worked on the
television series.
So,
you know,
I'm very comfortable right now,
I mean,
humans of New York,
uh,
has made me a,
let's just say I'm not,
I'm not working about worrying about peanut butter and sandwiches.
You know,
I'm,
I'm very comfortable.
Um,
with that being said,
uh,
I will say that humans of New York has raised,
I've,
I've made,
I've made a fraction of the money with humans of New York that we have raised
for charity.
They small fraction of the money that we've raised for charity.
Um,
I have turned down maybe more money than I've made,
uh,
from people who want to use my brand to partner with their brand.
You know,
um,
the big brands have offered me a lot of money to do.
Humans have,
and I'm just going to make up some names.
You know what I mean?
Like,
humans of Mercedes Benz,
humans have,
you know,
humans of China sponsored by Virgin Airlines.
These are all fake things and I'm making up right now,
but had resembled offers that have been made to me.
Um,
where were I make the dividing line is that I'm willing to make money as Brandon
Stanton.
Uh,
a big part of my income comes from speeches.
You know,
I give about 10 of these a year.
Um,
and,
uh,
that is a big part of my income.
Uh,
I have sell books is Brandon Stanton.
Um,
I don't,
so the name humans of New York to anyone.
I don't rent my brand to anyone.
Um,
and because I never want any piece of content that I share to have a single
motive,
I,
I've never broken that seal.
And you know,
it's been,
it's been so tempting,
but I just know if I break it once,
I'm never going to get it back.
Um,
so I,
for seven years,
I've never been compensated for a piece of content that I've posted on my blog.
Uh,
and you know,
that is,
that is the main delineation.
Um,
then I make between,
you know,
what can be monetized and what can't.
And because of that,
like I said,
I'm not worrying about peanut butter and sandwiches anymore.
Um,
but you know,
there is,
there is a little bit of an insecurity.
Am I going to look back and 40 years if everything,
suddenly everything's suddenly goes away on Facebook and Instagram,
nobody you're using anymore.
Am I going to be like,
Oh man,
I'm working the night shift and now
at 20 million followers 20 years ago,
maybe I should have tried a little harder to make some money.
But,
uh,
that's how I view it now.
Should have done this humans in New York lunchbox as well.
I had the chance.
Uh,
so you mentioned the book,
I'd like to chat about that for,
for a second because it's,
it's been the books at this point,
certainly,
but the,
at least as I understand it,
the first book,
so millions of copies,
certainly more than a million.
Was it easy to find a,
for that first book?
No.
Um,
I,
I barely did.
Um,
the Mcmillan,
uh,
God blessed them.
So,
like at the time,
you know,
I,
I think when I sold the book and I had a few hundred thousand Facebook fans and
it was growing so fast,
you know,
there was so much energy,
things are really taking off.
And I just thought,
oh my gosh,
you know,
everybody's going to want to publish this book.
Uh,
and,
and there's six big publishers,
I'm sure you know all this,
um,
or seven or something like that.
And you,
you,
the goal is to get all of them interested.
Um,
and so,
and then,
you know,
in the perfect world,
all of them are interested in,
then they bid against each other.
Right.
Um,
and so I only three of them would meet with me or four of them maybe.
and during those meetings I thought that I killed it.
You know,
I thought,
Oh man,
like,
ah,
then I described it so well,
I,
you know,
presented so well,
they're all going to be very interested.
And so we had an auction and the,
the bids were due by 12 o'clock,
noon on one day.
Uh,
and it's like at 11 o'clock I hadn't heard anything from my agent
and I was just like,
what's going on?
So I texted him and he goes,
Oh,
uh,
the first three dropped out there,
they didn't make it offer.
There's still one that we haven't heard from yet.
Uh,
and I'm just like,
oh my God,
you know,
because that book was,
well,
that book was my life raft because I didn't have any money at that time.
Was hoping to get a little bit of a book deal so I could,
you know,
pay my bills.
And I just remember I went to the y MCA and I just ran like five miles because I
thought it was going to be the worst day of my life.
Um,
and then when I got on the treadmill,
I found out that a McMillan had made a,
a,
a small but respectable offer.
Um,
and that's how I got a book deal by the skin of my teeth,
which I think was a,
which was lucrative for all parties involved.
And what were some of the reasons for not meeting with you or not putting in an
offer that they gave?
Because there's two types of books that have a history of not selling well,
uh,
well there's a lot of types,
but my mind fit two categories.
It was a photography book.
Photography's books don't sell based on conventional wisdom.
And it was a,
what they viewed as a regional book where it is a photography books center
centered on a single city,
therefore nobody's going to want it.
That was the,
that was,
that was the argument against publishing a humans of New York.
Oops.
Yeah.
This is,
I love these stories because they are the rule and not the exception for so many
things that turn into something.
Well,
things that are not derivative.
You know what I mean?
In my mind and my mind,
like the most valuable ideas,
the one that nobody's ever seen before.
Like,
that's when you've got the gold,
but you've got a better chance of just choosing something else that's good and
making something derivative on it.
Uh,
because then when you go,
when you go into these places and you pitch,
you can say,
oh,
this is the,
uh,
this is 50 shades of gray.
But you know,
with furries
it's like,
it's,
it's funny that like for me as an artist and as a creator,
the,
the last thing I ever want to do is be describing my work as it's this,
but with a twist,
you know what I mean?
Like I want to be creating something new.
Uh,
however,
in the marketplace,
the things that are,
have most likely chance of getting bought or things that people can,
can peg to other past successes.
And so when you walk in with something like what I thought was humans of New
York's greatest value,
which was there really wasn't anything else like it at the time,
um,
they viewed as a detriment.
But what are the comparables?
You're like,
ah,
that's the whole point there.
There aren't that right.
Copper bowls.
That fucking word.
I mean,
are you kidding me?
Like I just like the same thing.
You know,
when I was making the television series,
like the same thing,
it's like as an artist I want this to be like nothing else that's been,
that's like the only thing I care about is making something that's really unlike
anything else like that.
That is,
if it's like something else,
it's,
I don't really want to obsess over it for three years trying to make it,
you know,
my goal is to,
is to make something new and something fresh.
And when you're trying to get compensated for your work,
you know,
the thing that you care about the most as an artist is often the thing that's
held against you the most.
Uh,
because people are risk averse and they want to see something comparable that
has also done well.
What's next for you?
I mean,
if you do have five year plans,
three year plans and so on at this point,
or is it still 24 hours by 24 hours?
What's next for you?
I do.
I'm having a baby.
So that's going to be new,
having a baby in July.
So beyond that,
which is going to be new.
Um,
the,
like for me right now,
the biggest kind of artistic tension is knowing,
because of my experience on social media,
um,
the past seven years,
knowing,
knowing how social media works,
knowing the importance of output and content and daily content and,
and,
um,
engagement and things like that.
Um,
knowing how to build an audience on one hand and wanting to push myself as an
artist.
On the other hand,
um,
and you know,
what I really want to do as an artist is I kind of want to withdraw from the
daily,
you know,
output model.
Uh,
I want to work on things that have longer timeframes that are more polished and,
or maybe longer,
but take longer to produce and,
and more resources.
Uh,
but that in order to do that,
that requires me to kind of pull back from the blog,
um,
which,
you know,
the,
the golden rule of,
you know,
social media is keep engaging with your audience.
Keep connecting with your audience.
You know,
don't lose touch,
don't lose touch.
Don't lose touch.
Uh,
but the artist in me wants to go disappear for awhile and you know,
go into a dark cave and come out with something.
Uh,
so I think,
you know,
that is,
that is the main push and pull in my mind right now.
Um,
so I'm going to be going to the Philippines next month,
uh,
to work on,
I'm going to spend a month filming a documentary on somebody because I love
documentaries and I want to make a documentary that is very interesting.
So that might not be what's best for business or best for growing audience or
best buy social media metrics.
But that is,
that is what is exciting to me and it,
and it all comes back to that moment.
It's like,
I,
it's so funny and I think you're probably the same way,
is that we have these mantras and these things that we've learned,
uh,
that we stand on stage and we,
and we say,
and we,
and we think about,
you know,
don't wait for the perfect idea.
You know,
it's never going to seem perfect.
You just got to go after it.
Choose,
you know,
what is nourishing and the moment things like that.
Uh,
and if you're like me,
like I have to,
I have to preach to myself,
you know,
a lot,
and,
and tell myself the same thing that I'm telling other people because it's so
easy to kind of,
you know,
fall back into what everybody else is struggling with as well because you never
truly escape it.
And so,
you know,
one of the things that I do is,
I'd go back to that moment when I lost my job and I was walking in Chicago and I
asked myself,
you know,
if nothing mattered but,
but how I was spending my time,
you know,
what,
what would I,
what would be doing,
what would be most nourishing for me in any given moment?
Uh,
if it was,
if nothing else mattered except for how I spend my time.
Uh,
and you know,
I'm trying to remind myself of that,
you know,
the same thing.
I tell other people,
and right now I want to go to the Philippines and I want to make a documentary
and it might not be best for business and it might not be best for humans of New
York,
but it's what Brandon wants to do.
And so that is,
uh,
that is the North Star that I'm trying to follow.
Good for you,
man.
I'm excited for you to disappear for a little while.
That may come off the wrong way,
but you get the,
you get the sentiment behind it.
Yeah,
exactly.
And uh,
I have a random suggestion,
which is if you have not read cryptonomic on,
which is a book by Neil Stevenson,
also wrote snow crash.
I love snow crash.
So cryptonomic on part of the through line,
one of the narratives takes place in the Philippines.
So that could be,
that could be fun to pick up.
But Brendan,
thank you so much for taking the time today.
This was really a wonderful experience for me and thank you for being vulnerable
also.
And I'd be telling
filling in some of the color in the story of your life thus far.
Uh,
and uh,
it's,
it's been,
it's been really nice to get to know you a little better in this conversation.
Well,
thank you so much.
Um,
hope,
hope some of that's useful.
Yeah,
I think it is.
Is there anything else you would like to ask if people suggest to people and he,
any closing comments before we wrap up?
No,
I think that's okay.
I think that's it.
All right.
Awesome.
Well,
once again,
really appreciate you making the time,
uh,
particularly how much you think about how you spend your time to chat with me
and with everybody today and for everyone listening you can as always find links
to everything we have spoken about to all of Brandon's projects as well in the
show notes@tim.blog for slash podcast and until next time,
do what is nourishing for you in the moment or at least ponder the question.
And thanks for listening.
Hey guys,
this is Tim again.
Just a few more things before you take off.
Number one,
this is five bullet Friday.
Do you want to get a short email from me?
Would you enjoy getting a short email from me every Friday that provides a
little more soul of fun before the weekend and five bullet Friday is a very
short email where I share the coolest things I found or that I've been pondering
over the week.
That could include favorite new albums that I've discovered.
It could include Gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of weird shit that I've
somehow dug up in the other world of the,
as I
do.
It could include favorite articles that I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance,
and it's very short.
It's just a little tiny bite of goodness before you head off for the weekend,
so if you want to receive that,
check it out.
Just go to a four hour work week.com that's four hour work week.com all spelled
out and just drop in your email and you'll get the very next one and if you sign
up,
I hope you enjoy it.
This episode is brought to you by four sigmatic.
If you're a longtime listener of the show,
we're brand new to the podcast.
My favorite finish entrepreneurs who founded this company.
Of course,
I don't know that many Finnish entrepreneurs,
but they may be my favorites,
have something new that I've been loving and some of you are familiar with.
Four sigmatic.
I've used their products for years now.
There were introduced to me by an Acrobat of all folks and they tend to mix
different types of medicinal mushrooms into their products.
I have recently started using their Mecha,
which is a green tea,
which is designed as a coffee alternative and if you're trying to cut back on
caffeine as I am these days,
the match is a great option and one that I originally learned to love in Japan
has a very smooth texture to it.
They're macho blend in particular includes the amino acid [inaudible],
which helps to provide a,
let's call it balanced boost of energy without jitters and also includes the
adaptogen astrologists.
I'm pronouncing that correctly,
which may help with overall stress tolerance.
And for those of you who are wondering,
no,
the products don't taste like mushrooms.
If they say mushroom coffee for instance,
another product that I use,
it doesn't taste like mushrooms.
It tastes like coffee,
but you get to the nutritional benefits of some of these special ingredients.
So the products still taste like mushrooms and are enjoyable.
I offer them to my house guests and use them myself,
and I don't particularly want to drink anything that tastes like mushrooms.
So living on the folks that foursigmatic have designed a few special deals for
you guys,
my listeners,
which include many of my favorite products of theirs to check it out,
visit four sigmatic,
F,
O,
U R S,
I g m a t I c.com/tim Tim.
It's Tim,
Tim,
no space to see these special deals which are not offered anywhere else.
Remember to use the code.
Tim,
I don't know why they chose Tim,
but there we go.
Remember to use the code,
Tim,
Tim at checkout to receive your special discount.
Again,
that's foursigmatic.com forward slash Tim Tim and enter the Promo Code Tim.
Tim,
check it out.
This episode is brought to you by wordpress.com I love wordpress.
I have used it for so many years.
It's my goto platform for blogging and creating websites.
I use wordpress.com for everything every day.
My site,
tim.blog is built on it.
The websites for my books,
including tools of titans,
tribe of mentors,
all in wordpress.com and the founder Matt Mullenweg from my close friends has
appeared on the show many times.
Just search that moment with Tequila Ferris for quite an exciting time.
Whether you're looking to create a personal blog,
a business site,
or both,
you can make a really big impact right out of the box when you build on
wordpress.com and do being good company,
it's used by the New Yorker,
Jay z,
the owl,
say five 38 tech crunch,
Ted CNN time just to name a handful and one of my
friends@googleshallremainnamelesshastoldmethatwordpress.com offers the best out
of the box SEO imagining input and it's one of the many reasons that nearly 30%
of the Internet is run on wordpress.
You do not need experience or to hire someone that's perhaps the best part.
wordpress.com guide you through the entire experience.
They have hundreds of designs and templates that you can use and it's easy to
get started.
There's no need to worry about security upgrades,
posting any of that debt for 24 seven support,
and they're very,
very responsive questions.
They get right back to you,
and this allows you to create the highest quality with the least amount of
headache and fractions of you're building a website.
Harriet,
from my friends come to me and asked what I use,
what I recommend they use.
The answer is wordpress.com to check it out.
Do you want to get started today?
Learn more with a 15% discount off any new plan.
Go to wordpress.com forward slash Tim,
read your website and find a friend who's right for you.
So learn more.
Pick a look.
wordpress.com forward slash 10 15% off a brand new website.
Check it out.